[Applause]
I'm not gonna lie to you guys I am
actually pretty nervous about the
election not this this is fine
nervous about the election it's pretty
scary a woman might be the president you
guys it's kind of a fun joke to do at
the top see who's into jokes some people
are like I don't like him now he's being
serious on this comical program I don't
care who you're voting for pretty good
options this year pretty exciting
ah what a time to be alive for a little
bit longer this election folks is about
inspiration let me get down here with
you guys this election shut up I have a
limited amount of time
this election is about inspiration you
guys when Barack Obama was elected he
was the first black president that's
inspiring if Hillary Clinton as Hillary
Clinton wins this election she's the
first female president that's inspiring
if Donald Trump wins this election
that's inspiring for your average Joes
like me I'm not walking around assuming
one day I could be the president but now
it's like I don't know he did it what do
I have to do do I fill out a form do I
submit a tape how do I start to try to
be the president god I feel like I'm
still not connecting with you let me get
in here with you guys no no no no no no
no don't so no I'll get through
look at all these people that like race
to me I want to be in the front row now
it's like not even worth it for them
when you watch a debate let's stay on
point here the worst just we're right
here oops
all right I'll move geez not really a
team player right now I say can you move
I can't see the show he litter that's
what his thought I can't see the screen
if you're right here sir
he's not even turning around to see this
I've stopped tuning in at the Hilary
bits when you watch a debate you never
know what anyone's talking about you
always act like you do they reference
stuff you're like oh that's a good point
you don't know what they're saying and
then Donald Trump talks and you're like
I've said that before it's not a good
sign you got to be optimistic folks if
Donald Trump wins shut it shut it shut
if Donald Trump wins this election we're
all gonna get to die at the same time
that's special that's special but
dinosaurs and now us pretty cool and
yeah some people are watching at home
and you're like I don't like the Trump
jokes grow up and get used to it if he
wins this is the job creation he's
talking about
and for all you people in here who are
voting for Hillary you know you're gonna
get in the booth and you're gonna be
ready to vote for and then you're gonna
stop and you're gonna say to yourself
but what would it be like he said he
just knew whoever he wants to there's
only one way to find out if that's true
I don't want him to nuke anybody but
it's like how bright can these fireworks
get let me get a little deeper in here
you guys clap at anything and it makes
me feel good and bad at the same time
you get up here
really
thank you okay okay okay you're safe
you saw this happening you knew this was
gonna happen I wish I could get what I
want with this election I say we just
get another Kenyan for four more years
that's where I thought the joke stopped
and the manifesto started
I know Barack Obama's a US citizen all
of us know it but there's people who
don't think he is including someone who
might be the president so that's neat
that's like an added election bonus kind
of thing I like imagining that he's not
a US citizen to be the first black
president in this country with the
history of this country and the current
racial tension in this country that's
amazing but on top of it on top of it
you're gonna tell me he's not even a US
citizen what what it's yours
the job is yours Obama until you don't
want it anymore I hope to god I hope to
god on his last day in office he's just
like I gotta come clean about something
you guys
I'm not even a US citizen even the
people who hate Obama would be like
Barack come on
what you goose how did you do that we
looked into it you are literally the
only president we ever looked into it
for and if you don't think that's
impressive you do that you go to another
country and you get as far as president
you won't even get as far as mayor cuz
you don't even know what a mayor does
you thought you did when you were a kid
you're like a mayor runs the town I saw
it in a Richard Scarry bug you have no
idea you have no idea - but when Marion
Barry got caught smoking crack in the
90s people were like but oh my god he's
the mayor then Rob Ford in Toronto he
gets caught smoking crack maybe we as
people need to step back and ask
ourselves do mayor smoke crack do they
all smoke crack they might all smoke
crack and these two they just happen to
get caught you know how not everybody in
this room has a DUI but we've all been
eligible for one
[Applause]
it's no coincidence that tonight we are
in the Apollo Theater the election is
less than a week away an Apollo Creed
was wearing an American flag when a
Russian killed him do the right thing on
Tuesday thank you so much
[Applause]
you